[Music]
what's up guys it's day three here at
Gamescom Cologne I'm with Peter Brown
said Ford Peter you just been to see
dying light just like last year hello
everyone welcome to Gamescom day - I'm
Peter Brown here with sub for a peanut
yeah last year we saw dying light yeah I
think we both enjoyed it a little bit
kind of it spark or inspire you know
zombie yeah it was it was me Rosetta
meets zombie no but it's actually good
and making that comparison because this
year it's almost Dead Island meets
evolve so I was playing co-op with
another guy and we were essentially you
know running from zombies trying to set
up a bomb you know blow up this building
more or less so that humanity outside of
our area knew we were still there as
survivor okay yep so after doing that we
were trying to escape and get to you
know some sort of safe place anyway
along the way we were alerted that oh
crap there's a hunter after okay what's
a what's a hunter so they had another
guy manning a computer to the side all
right a surprise surprise all right
there is a super powerful super mobile
zombie that is now after you there's a
lot stronger than you okay ah and
basically he's going to hunt you down
this whole hunt
so it's basically the same thing you
haven't evolved only this time you're
not trying to kill the monster
necessarily you're trying to stay away
from all right but in order to prevent
it from killing you you can attack it
yourself so you have this guy chasing
you have a couple of things that you can
do you can detect it using this pulse
mechanic and then when it gets really
close you can use this UV lamp to sort
of set it a foot ablaze so yeah one
thing that you attack it you can
actually respawn using what are known as
hives okay if you destroy enough of the
hives that are on the map they can't
respond anymore you can actually go back
about your business nice
so is he is he there just to to troll
your game yes okay that's his only thing
and so the mechanic for that is
basically you can jump into strangers
games or jump into your friends games
all right based on however they're stood
up on your end and on their ins and this
is gonna be during this their
single-player experience right it's not
far away yeah it's not a separate mode
yes just during the main campaign okay
let's pretty seamless is this nice kind
of integration cool and they're set
points where you'll be able to do that
or is it kind of like I see my buddies
playing dying light right now I'm just
gonna troll him right here
like whatever he's doing it seems right
now at least based on the demo to be
limited to external in my you know
outside environment show um and I think
it also only happens at night okay yeah
so that might be part of it well that
you feel I you do I tell ya that makes
perfect sense all right fair enough
anyway no but we have played other you
know zombie based games I played send it
out on to yes yeah we wait it's gonna be
like our games come fing be so we go and
do the zombie bit like everyone any sees
they're like the fancy games all the
sci-fi stuff we do zombies some happen
oh yeah I think it's better this way
frankly so how does it feel like the
game's changed apart from that me
mechanic that they're showing since we
were there last year so now does they
have they've had some more time they've
developed some sort of light RPG
mechanics it's more like character
progression and so this game it you know
it's really meant to sort of inspire you
to be really mobile yeah you don't have
to do it that way
but the more that you do certain things
like you know climbing up buildings
leaping off roofs better you get and the
more Skills you unlock so at first it's
pretty cumbersome to do that so you
might feel better running around the
building yeah that's the sort of check
and balance to keep that that sunny was
the way it felt last year was you know
getting used to the the parkour
mechanics was it felt a little clunky at
first so I know exactly what you mean
but they did say that the height plays
in quite a lot to be effective because a
lot of verticality yeah and you'll
unlock things like being a little run on
walls and to run up walls better than in
the past
and as you attack monsters as well you
get a better are doing and it sounds
like the new hunter has the power to
sort of be quite vertical as well like
they can scale buildings much quicker
than you can scale buildings leave
across the map if you played na goth
which is a really odd reference to bring
up said I know it's a legacy in keen
legs II became free to play again put in
shooter there's a vampire type that does
that in the game your senior yeah this
monster can leap across the map leap up
buildings and so using that pulse
mechanic is really important if you want
to track sure well sounds all someone
got it I didn't get a play with you this
year next year next year it'll be back
alright that's dying light don't forget
we got plenty more coming out of games
come it's not over yet day three still
going plenty more to come stay tuned
here at games ball